hey everyone it's sarah thread sterner
sorry and calm and in this video i'm
gonna demonstrate how to wear and take
off a mask first let's talk about some
of the common mistakes that people make
whenever wearing a mask like this one
common mistake that people make is that
when they wear the mask they will wear
it under the nose another common mistake
is that people will fail to seal the top
of the mask around the nose and cheeks
in addition people will sometimes fail
to pull the mask under the chin people
also wear the mask upside down or
backwards and finally while wearing the
mask people will sometimes touch the
front of the mask which is considered
contaminated now let me give you some
tips on how to wear the mask so first
you need to determine which part
actually goes over your nose this part
or that part so to do that what you want
to do is you want to fill along those
edges and where your feeling for it is
like a metal type band that's sewn into
the mask that's easily flexible that can
fit over your nose and that's the top
part next what you want to do is you
want to determine which part of the mask
is the front versus the back and there's
two ways you can do this and if you're
using a mask with ear loops you can look
at the ear loops and where they are sewn
at this will be the area that goes on
the face so on this mask they're sewn
here so this is the part that goes over
my face also you can look at the pleats
of the mask and look at how they are
pointing when the pleats are pointing
downward this is the part that goes on
the outside versus the pleats that are
pointing upward that's the part that's
going to touch your face before we put
on a mask we want to perform hand
hygiene when using a face mask with ear
loops place each loop over the ears then
grasp the nose piece of the mask and
bring it to cover the bridge of the nose
then mold the nose piece of the face
mask with the finger tips of both hands
by starting at the bridge of the nose
and work outward toward the cheekbone
then grasp the nose piece of the face
mask and pull the bottom of the mask
under the chin when removing the mask
it's important to remember that the
front of the mask is considered
contaminated
therefore grasp the ear loops of the
mask with the fingertip
and removed from the face dispose or
clean and store for future use the mass
/ facilities protocol and then perform
hand hygiene ok so that wraps up this
video on how to wear and take off a mask
and don't forget to check out the other
videos in this nursing skills series